Avons-nous des traditions Elsa ?
Je suis désolée Elsa... C'est ma faute si nous n'avons pas de traditions familiales.
On va trouver les plus belles traditions qu'Anna et Elsa aient jamais vues !
Es-tu avec moi ?!
"On va faire du porte à porte, pour chercher des traditions de famille
Nous faisons des sucres d'orge
Sugar rush !
Vous coupez un arbre et l'habillez avec des bougies ?
J'adore ça !
Amenez l'inventaire !
D'accord, je suis Noël !
Ooh regardez nous avons notre renne !
Salut !
Woow, on passe vraiment un superbe moment !
Allons trouver ces traditions !
J'adore quand tu m'appelles pour passer ces moments, tu vois ce que je veux dire...
Un cake aux fruits !
Oh, dégueu !
Il est passé à travers moi...
Seulement en salles avec Coco